do you ever feel like there's still a
stigma being a part of a show called
teen mom when your life has really
evolved past that label
every day every day can you set the
record straight are you single are you
taken are you dating
my girls are starting to sleep by
themselves and they're getting older so
now i'm like
all right maybe maybe i should go on a
date or something
i love how you and your sisters
get all up in your mom's business i love
when you guys go through her
phone you've got opinions about who she
dates if my mom
edited a boyfriend now we already have
this test
down and we gave him like two months to
figure it all out
and then we test it
life's not always going to be easy but
it's only going to make us stronger
and that's all we can do i'm really
enjoying teen
mom 2 season 10 part b
how are you enjoying it how has this
season been for you so far
i think just watching the girls watching
them just grow
up on tv has been something i i will
always
be able to look back on there are times
that it's difficult
um just to air so much personal stuff
out there
but i know that so many other people can
relate and i think that's
at the end of the day that's what's
important to me what are you most
excited for the fans to see this season
i just think honestly just continue to
see me and my girls evolve
and also ali i just partnered with a
non-profit organization
to do some research and hopefully
depends we're seeing how ally's muscle
biopsies are
it will respond to the treatment that
they're doing
on it and we'll know in a moment so i
just having all of that play out on tv
i know yeah and that's so cool that
you're using your platform to
you know hopefully improve the not only
the life of your daughter but so many
others
around the world who are struggling with
similar issues
um is there one moment in
season 10 part b that
really sticks out as being the most
challenging or
you're maybe not looking forward to
reliving when that episode airs
i think going to the gynecologist and
doing that whole
exam may be a little uncomfortable to
have
on tv but at the end of the day i think
many of us women go through that
early detection is so important when it
comes to our health as women
so just keeping up with that and being
able to share that
ten years later on the show i never
would have expected [ __ ] you know
talking to my daughters about this on tv
or even talking about
or going through it on tv i never didn't
think we'd be here but we are
i went to the doctor the other day
because i was a little concerned about a
lump that i had in my
right breast when i i went for the
ultrasound they found a tumor in my
right breast
but they didn't seem to think that it
was cancerous i truly commend you for
being so brave and having so much
so much strength um i just want to know
how are you doing today
i'm doing great the last ultrasound they
measured
the tumor and it had grown but they
still don't think that it's anything
to be concerned about or have some kind
of procedure
so i am blessed and i'm so grateful
um other than that we're doing great we
really are
as it stands right now you do not need
to have surgery i do not need to have
the surgery
ah thank goodness so good to hear yes
so you guys know as we are getting older
we embrace all the fun stuff that
happens with becoming girls
how much did you tell them about your
health scare and how did they handle
everything
so i kind of explained to them the story
of when i started
my menstrual cycle and how that all
played out i was in fifth grade
um and then i kind of talked to them
about after menstrual cycles it's
important a week afterwards to
examine your breasts to make sure there
aren't any lumps or any anything that's
unrecognizable so i just want to be on
top of it i know that
in my family it was you didn't talk
about anything like that so i want them
to feel comfortable talking about it
moving forward
even it doesn't the floor is open
whatever they bring to the table is what
we'll talk about if you guys ever have
any questions for me you know that this
is
a safe place you can come to me with any
questions if you hear things at school
do you feel comfortable enough to come
to mommy yeah yeah
i want to talk a little bit about your
girls the twins we've got addie
how are they doing what's going on with
them what's the latest
they are doing great addie just started
addie's a little baller guys
she loves basketball she is
scoring all the hoops now loves soccer
so she's in that there weren't very very
many activities that they could all
three enjoy together
and alia was always in cheerleading so
once she stepped away from that she was
able to explore other activities
which was kind of cool to see their love
of an activity that they all get to
equally do together
and that was horseback riding lessons
and they
love i mean i honestly i cried i'm
emotional
af okay yeah that's okay
like they're uh ali and elia has had
such a rocky relationship
the past eleven years oh we have to deal
with
people bullying ally and then it's just
there's a different dynamic there with
how each of them struggle with ali
having muscular dystrophy
i just kind of want to check in and do a
little co-parenting check
how are things going between you and
corey at the moment
things are going great with me and corey
so we
honestly we put the girls best interests
at heart we told them no
cell phones until going into middle
school and we stuck
stuck to that usually if there's a
decision need
that needs to be made we make it
together i think that's what's going to
give our daughters
the stability in their childhood that
they need
how are things going between you and
jeremy
things with jeremy are great as well
he's actually out of town working
of course he works out of town a lot and
i mean we do what's best for addie
there's quite a few fans who are still
holding out hope
that you and jeremy could be end game
together
do you see these comments and what do
you make of them
no no i do see the comments even
when i do the questionnaires it's always
are you and jeremy gonna get back
together
you should get back with jeremy and the
answer is no
i think we have sealed that i personally
do not want to get back with jeremy
and we'll never be getting back together
i think we do well as being addy's
parents and at the end of the day that's
all it will ever be
so with that queen leah can you
can you set the record straight are you
single are you taken
are you dating i am single
my girls are starting to sleep by
themselves and they're getting older so
now i'm like
all right maybe maybe i should go on a
date or something
you know when they're with your dad for
a week i'm like all right it's
a little quiet in the house what makes a
great partner in your eyes what are some
of those qualities that you're looking
for
obviously loves kids compassionate
career driven and good work ethics is
marriage something that you think about
would you be open to that in the future
previously i got married because it was
just
religious reasons it was like if you
don't get married it's
not going to have sex out of wedlock so
i was like all right i'm getting married
and now i just feel like it puts a lot
of pressure on
your relationship and maybe it's not
that i'm being cold i just
i don't know why do we why do we
necessarily have to have papers to make
it a good relationship
so i don't know i i don't know i do hope
that you that you find somebody that
that makes your heart
happy because you really deserve it i
know how hard you work and what a
terrific mom you are so
finding that little i don't know uh
cherry on top at the end of the day
daddy's standing behind like behind the
computer she's going
hi addy how are you
addie i actually have a question for you
i love
how you and your sisters get all up in
your mom's business
i love when you guys go through her
phone you've got opinions about who she
dates tell me about that and and what do
you hope
your mom finds in maybe a future partner
if my
[Music]
what do you make your mom's friends go
through in order
to pass the test oh questions making
sure they never
forget oh okay would you cook for her
what's my mom's favorite collar what's
my mom's favorite animal
addy it's so good to see you and uh come
back and say goodbye when i'm done with
your mom
okay so i'll have to call
okay she said you'll have to call her oh
okay for sure
it's been such a joy getting to know you
through this show over the last 10 plus
years
have you thought about when you think it
might be time to say goodbye to the
cameras
uh i mean whenever honestly i'm here for
the
for the ride i've been a part of the
show from the beginning and
i stay committed to that i think what's
unique about teen mom is that it's not
just a show about you
leah it's about your girls it's about
your extended family it's about
their dads um how does everyone else
feel about being a part of the show do
your girls as they get older do you
think they like having the cameras
around as
much as you do i think sometimes they do
sometimes they don't if they
don't want to film they usually go to
their rooms or they go somewhere
else and i don't make them film at the
end of the day i let them decide if they
want to film or they don't want to come
is there a moment that sticks out
that you're you're so happy that it was
covered by the show that you
have it that you can always go back to
it and re-watch it and then on the flip
side is there a moment that you're like
oh
i wish the cameras hadn't have been
there or you cringe or you wish it
didn't happen
going through two differences it was
really hard struggling with addiction
was really difficult
and all of that stuff is on tv just not
really adult life
everything where you make the most
mistakes all of that is on tv
and the most embarrassing moment is
seeing myself on national television
and i know i'll never live that down
i'll always be known as the girl
on 16 and pregnant sister
you can't please come go
i think the best moments is just the
birth of my daughters and watching them
grow up on tv will always have
those memories for sure
and you know i i have to ask you you're
on a show called
teen mom 2 but i want to point out the
obvious that you're a really successful
woman
you're nearly 30 years old you're
terrific
in many arenas of your life do you ever
feel like there's still a stigma being a
part of a show called teen mom when
your life has really evolved past that
label
every day every day i mean but why would
they change the name of the show
uh you know it's it's it is
the show we started on so i definitely
think that that is definitely labeled
as that but it's okay like i continue it
i don't know
how would you even change that i would i
mean i
i don't know would you be open to a
spin-off leah's world
you know something like that where we
you know showcase you as a businesswoman
and growing
your empire and your family is that
something you've thought about yeah
it definitely is it definitely is
something i thought about i'm gonna keep
all my fingers and toes crossed
because that is a show that i think we
absolutely need and i just i just i'm
curious you know you've been through so
much over the last
10 plus years and i don't know if you
ever read the comments but there's just
so much praise for you online leah
people really commend you for
the growth and maturity and the
evolution that you've gone through and
how
even through the ups and downs you've
really prioritized
over everything else just being a really
loving and loyal
mom how does all that make you feel i
love everyone that has been a part look
you're gonna make me cry a little bit
yeah um i love everyone that has been
a part like i really do like i love
everyone that has been a part of
our story our journey from the very
beginning i'll always remain that
humble loving person that's just who i
am the first time i ever got on
an airplane and seeing
different places and without just a long
time that probably wouldn't have
happened for me so i think that i have a
different level of appreciation for mtv
and
and the show in itself my last question
for you
over 10 years of footage of you what do
you think
when you look back and you see all your
different looks and your transformations
throughout the year what goes through
your mind
i wish i could look back at my younger
self and tell her that she was beautiful
just the way she is
and that she's so loved and worthy of
so much in life because i think that i
was really young looking to
i don't know like just really young and
insecure
and trying to fit every trend
every style everything on social media
and then being on tv made it even more
difficult
and i wish i just would have been true
to who i was at the end of the day
and stayed true to now i am but it's
taken time it's taken a lot of growth
and healing to get
to the place i am now like just being
happy with me
and i i yeah i think that's it
but fashion trends girl do you remember
i was like scrunching my hair with a
bunch of gel
straightening my things what was that
what was that
[Music]
you